tension de l'opinion publique mais les
cabinets de conseil intervienne depuis
plus longtemps à l'hôpital avec une
accélération au début des années 2000
dans le cadre de la réorganisation
hospitalière
certains sociologues évoque même une
constante au cra si hospitalières ont eu
l'occasion de le dire ici puisque nous
en avons auditionne nous soient
intéressés monsieur le directeur général
par votre point de vue opérationnel sur
l'ensemble de ces questions et plus
spécifiquement sur les modalités de
recours par l'ap-hp à des prestations de
conseil cette audition est ouverte au
public et à la presse elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du sénat et en raison du
contexte ça me sert sanitaires les
collègues peuvent également intervenir
par visioconférence comme pour toutes
les personnalités auditionnées je
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission denquête est passible
de sanctions pénales qui peuvent aller
sur les circonstances de 3 à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45 à 100 mille
euros damende je vous invite donc à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levé la main droite
et dit je le jure je le jure merci
monsieur le directeur général je voulais
c'est maintenant la parole pour une
intervention liminaire d'environ une
quinzaine de minutes si vous en êtes
d'accord
sur la base peut-être des éléments de
questionnaires quand vous a déjà
transmis ensuite madame la rapporteure
puis nos collègues pourront vous
interrogez je vous laisse maintenant la
parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
rapporteure mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je vais rentrer directement dans le vif
du sujet
effectivement dans les hôpitaux on est
beaucoup sollicité par les cabinets de
conseil et les cabinets de consultants
et vous avez rappelé que je suis depuis
un peu plus de 8 ans directeur général
de la séance publique et c'est une des
premières décisions que j'ai prises
quand je suis arrivé à l'assistance
publique c'est de mettre fin à
des prestations et à ne pas utiliser des
marchés qui avaient été ouverts avec des
grands cabinets de consultants pour des
prestations stratégique pour pour la
paix pour des montants qui était qui a
été significatif et si je me réfère au
rapport de la chambre régionale des
comptes qui a couvert les années
2010-2015 il ya un thème qui est un net
ralentissement depuis fin 2013 à partir
de novembre 2013
j'ai été nommé le 13 novembre le recours
aux conseils en gestion et ou en
stratégie a été plus limité à recouvrer
des montants plus modestes la plupart
des contrats et on était passé à
l'initiative des groupes hospitaliers il
n'a plu notamment aucune prestation de
conseil auprès du directeur général
pourquoi cela
parce que il me semblait effectivement
que la manière dont on
devait gouverner un grand groupe
hospitalier je rappelle juste le paysage
de l'assistance publique hôpitaux de
paris
un budget de 8 3 milliards d'euros par
an 100 mille personnes qui travaillent
environ 800 services médicaux répartis
dans six grands groupes hospitaliers le
premier chu européen ils représentent
10% de l'ensemble des lits
d'hospitalisation de france et un peu
plus de 40% de l'ensemble de la
recherche clinique de france avec
beaucoup de un système d'information
développer complexe avec
la gestion d'un grand parc immobilier
avec une des plus grandes blanchisserie
de france etc etc donc c'est un c'est un
grand ensemble
sur lequel on a beaucoup de décisions
stratégiques à prendre beaucoup
d'expertisé à avoir
il m'a semblé que il valait mieux avoir
et je pense que c'est je me suis
beaucoup retrouver dans un certain
nombre de questions que vous posiez
internaliser les expertises plutôt que
de reposer sur des cabinets extérieurs
et donc encore une fois je ne citerai
pas le nom de ces deux de ses grands
cabinets qui avaient des marchés assez
récurrent avec l'assistance publique et
nous nous sommes dit que nous nous nous
développerions
une expertise interne que nous avons
développé ça s'appelle la direction la
stratégie de la transformation dans
laquelle nous avons des profils ce texte
ce texte qui j'espère sera très
largement voté mais en votant ce texte
je la compagne d'un message à nos
collègues élus territoriaux c'est à eux
de reprendre le flambeau le flambeau de
ses responsabilités nouvelles que le
législateur leur a confié je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le vice président la
parole est à monsieur dominique potier
pour le parquet pour le groupe
socialiste
et pour cinq minutes je suis pas
d'alsace mais je vous connais quand même
monsieur le président madame la ministre
comme la présidente de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur cher vincent
nous sommes réunis pour
du nord
jean du grand est ce que nous aurions dû
traiter cette question et c'était tout à
fait possible ce n'est pas faute
dallaire de mobilisation que nous ayons
fait alors je vais répondre par avance
puisque nous avons eu le débat en
commission je vais répondre par avance à
trois idées fausses car mon avis sont
installés dans les esprits
la première serait que comparaison n'est
pas raison parce que c'est vrai que le
trafic allemand le trafic alsaciens sont
très proches de graphiquement mais si
nous prenons les comparaisons sur des
axes plus important sur un plus grand
périmètre ce qu'il convient de faire
pour le trafic international par exemple
de francfort dijon lyon tout le sillon
rhodanien
alors les deux trafics sont absolument
comparable et une différence de
tarification peut provoquer ceux des
ports deuxième élément c'est
le
préfet
même le rapporteur mes chers collègues
nous poursuivons nos travaux avec
l'audition de monsieur martin hirsch
directeur général de l'assistance
publique-hôpitaux de paris depuis huit
ans je le salue je lui souhaite la
bienvenue et jeu long
on remercie
[Musique]
même le rapporteur mes chers collègues
je
holmes
même l'europe
même le rapporteur mes chers collègues
nous poursuivons
même la branche est
[Musique]
merci monsieur le directeur général je
voulais c'est maintenant la parole pour
une intervention liminaire d'environ une
quinzaine de minutes si vous en êtes
d'accord
sur la base peut-être des éléments de
questionnaires quand vous a déjà
transmis en 7
on
même le rapporteur mes chers collègues
nous poursuivons nos travaux et
la route
même le rapporteur mes chers collègues
nous poursuivons nos travaux avec
l'audition de monsieur martin hirsch
directeur général de l'assistance
publique-hôpitaux de paris depuis huit
ans je le salue je lui souhaite la
bienvenue et je le remercie de nous
avoir rejoints cet après midi
notre commission denquête a entrepris
d'évaluer l'ampleur du recours par les
personnes publiques à des prestations de
conseil et d'en comprendre les ressorts
ainsi que les modalités dans le secteur
de la santé le recours aux services de
plusieurs cabinets de conseil dont
mckinsey dans l'organisation de la
campagne de vaccination a
particulièrement retenu l'attention de
l'opinion publique mais les cabinets de
conseil intervienne depuis plus
longtemps à l'hôpital avec une
accélération au début des années 2000
dans le cadre de la réorganisation
hospitalière
certains sociologues évoque même une
consultant cratie hospitalière ils ont
eu l'occasion de le dire ici puisque
nous en avons auditionné soit intéressé
monsieur le directeur général par votre
point de vue opérationnel sur l'ensemble
de ces questions et plus spécifiquement
sur les modalités de recours par l'ap-hp
à des prestations de conseil cette
audition est ouverte au public et à la
presse elle est retransmise en direct
sur le site internet du sénat mais en
raison du contexte alice et sanitaires
les collègues peuvent également
intervenir par visioconférence comme
pour toutes les personnalités
auditionnées je rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
denquête est passible de sanctions
pénales qui peuvent aller sur les
circonstances de 3 à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45 à 100 mille
euros d'amendé je vous invite donc à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levé la main droite
et dit je le jure je le jure merci
monsieur le directeur général je voulais
c'est maintenant la parole pour une
intervention liminaire d'environ une
quinzaine de minutes si vous en êtes
d'accord
sur la base peut être des éléments de
questionnaires quand vous a déjà
transmis ensuite madame la rapporteure
puis nos collègues pourront vous
interrogez je vous laisse maintenant la
porte
merci monsieur le président madame la
rapporteure mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
j'ai rentré directement dans le vif du
sujet
effectivement dans les hôpitaux on est
beaucoup sollicité par les cabinets de
conseil et les cabinets de consultants
et vous avez rappelé que je suis depuis
un peu plus de 8 ans directeur général
de la séance publique et c'est une des
premières décisions que j'ai prises
quand je suis arrivé à l'assistance
publique c'est de mettre fin à
des prestations et à ne pas utiliser des
marchés qui avaient été ouverts avec des
grands cabinets de consultants pour des
prestations stratégique pour pour la
paix pour des montants qui était qui a
été significatif et si je me réfère au
rapport de la chambre régionale des
comptes qui a couvert les années
2010-2015 il ya un thème qui est un net
ralentissement depuis fin 2013 à partir
de novembre 2013 qu j'étais nommé le 13
novembre le recours aux conseils en
gestion et ou en stratégie a été plus
limité à recouvrer des montants plus
modestes la plupart des contrats et on
était passé à l'initiative des groupes
hospitaliers il n'a plu notamment aucune
prestation de conseil auprès du
directeur général
pourquoi cela
parce que il me semblait effectivement
que la manière dont on
devait gouverner un grand groupe
hospitalier je rappelle juste le paysage
de l'assistance publique hôpitaux de
paris
un budget de 8 3 milliards d'euros par
an 100 mille personnes qui travaillent
environ 800 services médicaux répartis
dans six grands groupes hospitaliers le
premier chu européen ils représentent
10% de l'ensemble des lits
d'hospitalisation de france et un peu
plus de 40% de l'ensemble de la
recherche clinique de france avec
beaucoup de un système d'information
développer complexe avec eux
la gestion d'un grand parc immobilier
avec une des plus grandes blanchisserie
de france et s'est arrêté là donc c'est
un c'est un grand ensemble
sur lequel on a beaucoup de décisions
stratégiques à prendre beaucoup
d'expertisé à avoir
et il m'a semblé que il valait mieux
avoir et je pense que c'est je me suis
beaucoup retrouver dans un certain
nombre de questions que vous posiez
internaliser les expertises plutôt que
de reposer sur des cabinets extérieurs
et donc encore une fois je ne citerai
pas le nom de ces deux de ses grands
cabinets qui avaient des marchés assez
récurrent avec l'assistance publique et
nous nous sommes dit que nous nous nous
développerions
une expertise interne que nous avons
développé ça s'appelle la direction la
stratégie de la transformation dans
laquelle nous avons des profils
d'experts dont certains ont pu commencer
leur carrière dans le conseil ou sur le
terrain ou alterner entre les uns et les
autres mais que nous recrutons
peut-être que certains iront dans le
dans le conseil après compte tenu de
leurs compétences mais cela permet
d'avoir une équipe interne qui connaît
les établissements qui entre dans le
cadre de nos choix
stratégiques et techniques qui nous
éclairent et pour vous donner le type de
domaines sur lesquels ils interviennent
cela va depuis le travail que l'on fait
sur le fonctionnement des blocs
opératoires les durées de séjour des
patients
la fluidité des parcours des patients
dans les différents domaines entre les
courts séjours des soins de suite le
long séjour
le fonctionnement du circuit du
médicament etc etc qui sont des domaines
majeurs
et donc là dessus on a des équipes qui
sont qui sont compétentes ce que jusque
jeu donc je vois la compétence et dont
la compétence est reconnue par les par
les acteurs hospitaliers et qui font ce
ce travail alors je n'ai pas et je n'ai
pas fait et les quais libre de ce que ça
a changé en termes de dépenses
pour mais je pourrais le faire parce que
j'ai pas compter le nombre de personnes
que l'on avait mais
c'est
me semble-t-il plus opérationnels pour
nous plus cohérent avec les valeurs
hospitalière d'avoir des interlocuteurs
qui ont fait le choix de travailler à
l'hôpital ont fait le choix de prendre
un statut public
et probablement c'est aussi en tout cas
à l'heure plus économique que de faire
appel à des cabinets de conseil il
n'empêche que bien évidemment pour des
sujets circonscrit et technique nous
faisons appel à des
dépenses de conseil
dont l'ordre de grandeur est et les
questions qui m'étaient posées portait
sur les 3 dernières années de l'ordre de
ces mêmes le vrai pour les cinq
dernières années de 2 5 millions d'euros
par an 2 5 millions d'euros par an donc
on a calculé ça sur les trois années
19 20 21 pour regarder ce que ça donnait
ça donne effectivement 7 millions 651
1890 euros / je rappelle un budget de 8
3 milliards et pour vous donner
peut-être là la décomposition de ces
grands postes de dépenses il y à un
million et demi qui représente les
prestataires qui nous aident pour le
codage des actes
donc comme vous savez pour que l'hôpital
se fasse payer il faut qu'ils
transforment
l'intervention d'une
d'une opération de la vésicule biliaire
en un code qui transmit à la sécurité
sociale déclenché le financement qui
sont des opérations
techniques que nous sous traitons en
partie auprès de cabinets spécialisés
tout en travaillant à des outils
permettant d'automatiser ce travail le
sujet est de ne pas faire en sorte que
les médecins passent trop de temps il
déteste cela ils sont mais maintenant on
greffe du codage des actes de faire ce
travail
assez rébarbatif
si je prends les autres postes de
dépenses
c'est un million cent sur les les outils
innovants par exemple nous avons fait
des prestations pour regarder comment
nous pouvions transformer notre
organisation logistique est ce que nous
devions faire des plateformes
logistiques plutôt que le fonctionnement
interne il y à 1 millions sur trois ans
pour les prestations de communication
il ya un domaine dans lequel on utilise
les conseils qui sont l'organisation des
élections professionnelles pour lequel
on sous traite une partie de
l'organisation
nous avons fait appel à du conseil sur
la gestion de notre parc logement
et nous avons bien évidemment
les expertises du chsct que je fais
rentrer là dedans et pendant cette
période là pour l'ordre de 260 milles
euros pendant la crise qu vide nous
avons dépensé 140 3000 euros on
conseille pendant ces deux dernières
années donc je pense que c'est des
choses qui sont assez assez modeste
dans le montant total
des dépenses de la php
jeu précision à ces dépenses se
rajoutent celles qui ont trait à au
système d'information que je n'ai pas
intégrés dans ce décompte et qui en
matière de conseils de conseil
stratégique
ses lèvres pendant la même période
pendant 3 ans à 5 million deux cent
mille euros avec
différentes prestations
de d'assistance à aux évolutions nos
systèmes d'information et également par
exemple pour un peu plus de 200000 euros
nous avons une prestation pour
accompagner la réalisation de notre
schéma directeur les choses se sont de
telle sorte que
moi j'avais remarqué cela
auparavant vous savez que parfois
on a des rapports faits par des cabinets
d expertise tout à fait compétent qui
vous livre des tonnes de documents qui
sont rangés dans un coin et donc il faut
conseiller quelqu'un ils n'ont pas se
substituer à celui qu'on conseille et
donc par exemple si je prends le système
d'information nous avions deux personnes
à plein temps pour définir le le schéma
directeur aidé d'un cabinet de conseil
mais ce n'est pas le cabinet de conseil
qui se substituait à nos personnels
je précise tout de suite qu'en matière
de système d'information
nous avons au delà des prestations de
conseil stratégique beaucoup de
prestataires ce qui est à mon sens un
autre sujet mais qu'elle n'a un autre
problème qui est que les je pense que
nous l'avons en commun avec beaucoup
d'établissements publics
les conditions dans lesquelles nous
pouvons embaucher et rémunérer des
spécialistes
font que parfois nous ne pouvons pas
nous doter des bonnes compétences et que
du coup il ya une partie de l'aide à la
maîtrise d'ouvragé de l'assistance
technique
qui est confiée à des prestataires
extérieurs
et qui coûte plus cher à la puissance
publique
je vous dis en exemple que pour la
hotline des systèmes d'information on a
aujourd'hui un système mixte avec à la
fois du personnel assistance publique
est à la fois des prestataires
extérieurs
de telle sorte qu'on puisse à un moment
donné
probablement
réinternaliser ré internaliser les
choses dans quelques temps
mais bon on est passé de quelque chose
qui est externalisée à quelque chose qui
est mixte avec une note hotline sur
lequel répondent aujourd'hui
indifféremment des gens qui sont
viennent de cabinet de deux sociétés de
l'extérieur
et des gens qui sont de personnel ap et
je pense qu'on arrivera dans les
prochaines années à pouvoir internaliser
complètement les choses on a un gros
travail pour faire en sorte que les
grilles de rémunération
puisque s'adapter à ces
problématiques
pendant la crise qu vide
mon a été
approché par un certain nombre de deux
cabinets de conseil qui y compris pour
des une assistance gratuite nous n'avons
pas eu recours à cela en revanche et ça
a été très apprécié il y a eu
individuellement des membres de sociétés
de conseil qui était au chômage
technique pendant cette période et qui
sont venus avec les autres renforts dans
nos renforts
on a bénéficié de quelques milliers de
renforts notamment pendant la première
vague
travailler avec eux avec l'accord de
leur employeur mais dans des conditions
dans lesquelles jal à dire comme toute
une série de bénévoles on a bénéficié ça
me permet de le souligner devant le le
sénat d'une solidarité absolument
extraordinaire les personnels navigants
des avions qui étaient cloués au sol
sont venus nous aider quand il ya eu
toute une série de professionnels qui
sont venus nous aider de manière
bénévole je crois qu'ils étaient
rémunérés en chômage partiel pendant
cette période là mais ça a été quelque
chose de d'extrêmement utile d
extrêmement utile pour vous donner un
exemple
certains de ces professionnels ont
contribué à
nous aider à monter
le système dit qu vie d'homme de suivi à
domicile
des patients atteints de co vide qui a
concerné cinq cent mille malades et donc
on pour lequel on a organisé des grandes
plateformes et c'est expertise et ses
compétences là on était tout à fait
utile dans ce dans ce domaine
[Musique]
ensuite il ya toute une variété bien
évidemment je suis à disposition pour
laisser les fichiers avec les documents
permettant de de regarder les
différentes
prestations auxquelles ont fait recours
auxquels on a recours mais effectivement
il me semble qu'il est possible
de définir et d'appliquer la stratégie
d'un grand établissement comme le nôtre
en ayant une expertise interne
stratégique
mais en
n'ayant pas besoin
d'avoir des conseils stratégiques de
grands cabinets anglo-saxons ou
français en revanche je pense qu'il est
impossible à l'état actuel
d'être efficace et je ne pense pas que
ça soit
moi je le fais sans que ça me pose de
problème de pouvoir avoir sur des points
ponctuelle des
éclairages de d'experts je citais le
patrimoine mobilier comme on gère les
logements on n'a pas une équipe
spécialiste de cela et c'est tout à fait
utile de voir des des cabinets de
conseil qui ont travaillé avec d'autres
bailleurs etc qui peuvent nous apporter
cela pour des prestations
limitez technique et
suivent puis il ya cette question
notamment dans les systèmes
d'information
de cette sous traitance importantes à
des
grandes sociétés en général française ou
internationale
mettant française qu internationale pour
lequel il est extrêmement compliqué de
tout internaliser dans les conditions de
deux de fonctionnement à tel point qu'on
s'est
posé la question
de savoir si on n'avait pas intérêt à
créer une sorte de filiale informatique
de l'assistance publique
qui soit une filiale on a une petite
filiale qui est la filiale
internationale et il ya quelques années
on s'était avant le col gidon n'a pas
réactiver cette réflexion des saveurs si
on n'avait pas intérêt à voir une
filiale permettant d'avoir des
conditions de fonctionnement plus souple
pour pour pour l'informatique parce
qu'il est extrêmement compliqué dans un
établissement public à caractère
administratif de se passer de sous
traitants
merci beaucoup monsieur le directeur
général je pense que je me fais
l'interprète de mes collègues en vous
disant que nous avons apprécié cet
exposé clair concrets précis bref mais
quasiment exhaustif sur beaucoup de
questions qu'on avait vous posez donc
très sincèrement je vous en remercie je
vais passer maintenant la part de madame
la rapporteure pour les premières
questions j'en ai aussi plusieurs à vous
poser mais je ne doute pas que mes
collègues nous en aurons également
madame leur apporte
merci monsieur le président chers
collègues sur le directeur général moi
aussi je voudrais vous remercier pour
vos propos relativement clair que vous
avez pu tenir et je retiens que
vous avez effectivement déclaré que dès
votre arrivée vous avez mis fin à
certains cabinets de consultants jugeant
que les prestations étaient trop peu
nombreuses
et puis je voudrais aussi profité de ce
moment pour
nous dire qu'on peut s'accorder qui sont
le fait que dans le domaine hospitalier
il y a beaucoup de compétences
nous avons pu d'ailleurs le vérifier
pendant la crise sanitaire qui
malheureusement n'est pas n'est pas
terminée et ma première question j'en ai
j'en ai d'autres comment les prestations
des cabinets conseils ont-elles été
perçu par les personnels de l'ap-hp
puisqu'il ya eu des recours nous l'avait
dit un des cabinets privés comment cela
était ressentie par les personnels
comme plutôt mal je
mon excitation et montrent plutôt mal et
pour la chose suivante
autant et y compris chez le corps
médical
le fait de travailler sur un projet
donné avec un regard extérieur de deux
consultants sur un projet la conception
du ça ne pose aucun problème mais ils
sont parfois demandeurs autant
moi je n'ai pas mis beaucoup de temps
pour m'en apercevoir autant il
partageait cette vision que de se dire
que d'avoir des sorte d'abonnement
auprès de grands cabinets de consultants
et de personnes pour lequel en fait
l'hôpital n'était qu'un client même si
plusieurs des gens de très grande
qualité qui connaissent bien n'était pas
perçue comme comme comme quelque chose
de positif donc j'ai eu de leur part
aucune récrimination quand on a mis fin
à ces à ses prestations
questions d'ordre plus général cette
fois ci
on a auditionné une autre commission a
auditionné santé publique france etc de
votre point de vue est ce que le fait
qu'il y ait multiplication des agences
ne conduit-elle pas une dispersion des
compétences et une fille née à un
recours plus important aux cabinets
conseils
alors moi je ne crois pas alors
comme je
certain âge j'ai connu l'époque où il
n'y avait pas les agences sanitaires
j'ai connu l'époque où il les expertises
étaient dans les seules directions
d'administration centrale qui était
ce qu'on a reproché à l'époque du sang
contaminé etc et c'est à la suite est
d'ailleurs à l'initiative du sénat
dans d'abord la loi de 19 du 4 janvier
1993 puis dans celle de juillet 1998
compte est créé les agences sanitaires
et alors justement pour permettre à
l'état de re disposer d'une expertise
qui soit vraiment une expertise publique
et il ya eu des discussions il ya eu
d'ailleurs
des discussions au sénat si vous
permettez
si vous permettez
là dessus
le ministère avait proposé de faire une
seule agence pour la sécurité
alimentaire et la sécurité du médicament
ce qui a été refusé par le sénat
c'était en 1998
donc je dis juste là parce que c'était
pardon de faire cette petite parenthèse
qui était très intéressante avec la
crainte que les aliments soient
assimilés à des médicaments et que
et il ya eu un choix qui a été fait de
faire des agences spécialisées comme il
en existe maintenant dans dans
différents pays
moi je
quand on regarde y'a une agence sur le
médicament il l'ensemble des produits de
santé il ya une agence aujourd'hui sur
l'alimentation et l'environnement il y
avait effectivement
une une agence sur le suivi
épidémiologique et santé publique france
et sur l'information
en santé avec d'ailleurs la fusion de
deux trois ou quatre de trois ou quatre
organismes via l' agence de biomédecine
qui
il ya donc je vais pas les énumérer tout
mais je ne crois pas que c'est pas je
pense que cette spécialisation
est plutôt cohérente avec des expertises
qui sont quand même assez différent d'un
domaine à l'autre mais l'objectif était
précisément ce gars s'est réinstallé
s'était pas les cabinets de conseil à
l'époque c'était le fait que dans les
années 90 on s'est rendu compte que le
décideur public
était dépendant d'experts complètement
externe qui en même temps était expert
pour l'ensemble des industriels comme il
était pour l'état et donc il y avait ce
problème de liens et de conflits
d'intérêts et donc on a construit
quelque chose avec à la fois une
expertise interne c'est-à-dire des gens
à plein-temps agents publics consacrés à
100% pour ça
pouvant travailler avec des experts
externes parfois expert en même temps
pour l'industrie mais dans des
conditions dans lequelles ils n'avaient
pas le dernier mot le monopole de l
expertise donc moi je je
alors si vous je me souviens pour avoir
été directeur de cabinet du ministre de
la santé
au moment où ces agents s'étaient créés
la coordination est assurée par le
ministre qui réunissait tous les
mercredis matins avant le conseil des
ministres l'ensemble des responsables
des agences de sécurité sanitaire pour
regarder donné leur feuille de route
être informée et a donc cette
coordination qui est aujourd'hui assurée
par papa par le ministère et par un
ministère qui s'est d'ailleurs étoffé
depuis je ne pense pas que ça puisse
être le prétexte ou la cause de
l'utilisation de
d'expertisé ou de cabinets de conseil
stratégique
merci on va revenir aujourd'hui
je sais danse du domaine public mac il
sait aurait qaarsut 13,5 millions
d'euros pendant la crise sanitaire
essentiellement à partir de décembre
pour l'organisation de la campagne
vaccinale
quel est d'après vous la plus value d'un
cabinet de conseil généraliste comme
mckinsey dans la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique de santé publique
écoutez je ne sais pas précisément donc
nous on n'a pas eu à
travailler avec eux
et
donc je n'ai pas d'éléments
d'appréciation
autorisée
ou direct là dessus
moi le sentiment que j'ai vu deux
dans un grand hôpital
c'est que
in fine est
l'organisation de la vaccination a été
performante je ne sais pas quelle est la
part des uns et des autres mais je me
souviens de l'époque vous parliez de
décembre 2020 et de début du tout début
de l'année 2000 21 qui part il ya un
siècle mais qui était il ya treize mois
ou 12 mois et demi ou
tombés à bras raccourcis sur
l'organisation logistique etc je pense
que les choses se sont fait des défis
absolument incommensurable mais se sont
faits dans deux
dans de bonnes conditions
alors ensuite je ne sais pas quelle a
été vraiment je parle en sous serment je
ne vais pas inventer quelque chose que
je ne connais pas donc je ne sais pas
quel a été l'apport des différents
cabinets là dedans mais en tout cas en
tant que
acteurs de la vaccination puisqu'on a dû
faire six cent mille injection à
l'assistance publique acteurs de la
vaccination on considère qu'
on a pu voir de près l'ensemble des
défis logistiques organisationnel qui
ont été faits et qui ont été relevées
je crois qu'on est d'accord
là dessus
ma question plus précisément c est ce
que vous pensez que nous avons besoin
d'avoir recours à ce type de cabine et
j'appelle mckinsey où ou autre pour la
mise en oeuvre d'une politique publique
c'est ça la question oui j'ai bien
compris votre j'ai compris votre
question en dehors de votre savoir où on
en savoir sur
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
nécessaire et utile
alors mais vraiment mon approche va être
et qu'en
face à un
enjeu majeur
et dans lequel éventuellement il faut
pouvoir
mobiliser de l' expertise très
rapidement
je comprends qu'elles puissent ne pas
être disponibles en interne
alors ensuite est ce qu'il est capable
et ce qu'il est possible d'aller
recruter
des dizaines de personnes tout de suite
ou est ce qu'il vaut mieux faire appel à
des expertises constitué quoi vraiment
bas je m'arrête là parce que je tout cas
ce que je peux dire c'est que je
comprends comment face à un défi il faut
tout d'un coup aller chercher d'autres
expertises que celles qui sont
disponibles pour pouvoir déployer à très
grande échelle ces dispositifs
excusez-moi président je poursuis dans
ma rue biologique et après on laissera
la parole bien évidemment nous espérons
tous que nous n'allons pas encore
traversé une crise aussi grave que celle
que nous traversons encore aujourd'hui
et en europe nous avons quand même une
expérience nous tirons une expérience de
ce moment dramatique pour pour beaucoup
dans le pays est ce que vous pensez que
si malheureusement nous deux jurys
devrions revivre une telle crise nous
serions exactement dans la même
situation c'est à dire à avoir recours à
des cabinets pour nous accompagner dans
des stratégies publiques des politiques
publiques
je pense que celles et ceux qui ont pu
connaître la valeur ajoutée de ces
cabinets pourrais vous répondre mais
juste faire une remarque peut être
d'ordre psychologique il est peut-être
internaliser dans la puissance publique
et parfois par le regard qui est porté
sur lever les fonctionnaires et les
administrations qu'eux mêmes ne vont pas
être capable de faire quelque chose et
que quelqu'un qui a une étiquette avec
marc et anglo saxon des clients
prestigieux d utiliser un anglicisme
track-record remarquable sera mieux
faire donc si j'ai à dire
toute suspicion porté sur les pouvoirs
publics
de leur incompétence leur incapacité à
faire
acom rétroaction de pousser à aller se
réfugier derrière le recours à des
grands cabinets dont on se considère pas
ce que les très grandes entreprises
mondiales travaillent avec eux que ça va
inspirer confiance cet aspect
psychologique n'est probablement pas à
aa
lisez là dedans mais voilà encore une
fois ça n'est pas une expertise poussée
mais je suis sûr de cela quand il ya une
sorte de présomption de et donc toute la
confiance qui peut être mise dans les
acteurs publics aide à pouvoir faire que
les acteurs publics déploient leurs
forces
bien joué vous posez une ou deux
questions et puis ensuite selon prendre
des questions de nos collègues également
pourrait revenir sur votre le tout début
de votre propos liminaire avant toute
chose j'ai été troublé par ce début de
propos quand vous avez dit en arrivant
l'ap-hp j'ai découvert que
l'administration était beaucoup
sollicités sous-entendu par les cabinets
de conseil bien sûr bon si je suis un
peu plus me fait un peu plus naïfs que
je ne suis au naturel il me semble que
c'est plutôt normalement le mouvement
inverse auquel on devrait s'attend et
celui là qu'on peut éventuellement
critiquer ou du moins essayer d'évaluer
parce que nous on essaye de comprendre
donc est-ce que vous pouvez en quelques
mots rapidement revenir sur le sujet
parce que c'est un peu perturbant
alors c'est perturbant mais c'est la
réalité
c'est à dire que
effectivement
c'est un général dans le sens de
différentes manières d'ailleurs
de vous demander rendez vous de vous
proposer des offres de venir se
présenter également beaucoup
d'organisation de
séminaires
r
conférence dans lesquelles
ces cabinets sont
organisateurs sponsors
et c est quoi par ailleurs je je
respecte tout à fait leur travail et il
ya des gens tout à fait compétent mais
ça se transforme c'est plus de la
sollicitation
que que dans l'autre sens c'est très
très très très fréquents merci la
réponse est parfaitement clair elle
répond entièrement à ma question vous
avez évoqué très rapidement toute heure
la possibilité d'évaluer au moins
grossièrement l'équilibré économique de
cette réalisation je ne vais pas vous
demander au nom de la commission une
étude indiscutable sur le sujet mais si
vous pouviez bien sûr une approche
d'ailleurs elle sera considérée comme
une approche bien sûr évidemment mais
pour nous donner un désordre de grandeur
voilà si ça vous est possible parce que
ça nous ferait 30 août a fait une petite
question aussi très rapide
la cour des comptes que la commission
des finances auditionné ce matin sur la
transformation numérique du ministère de
la justice évoqué une donnée qu'elle
avait déjà évoqué d'ailleurs il ya deux
ans dans un autre rapport à la
commission des finances sur les grands
projets informatiques de l'état qui veut
que quand on a affaire à des cabinets de
conseil il faut qu'il ya au moins 30% de
l'équipe projet qui soit constitué de
fonctionnaires de la maison en quelque
sorte qui passe la commande est ce que
cet ordre de grandeur de participation
vous parlez est ce que vous en avez
l'expérience alors c'est un peu ce à
quoi je faisais allusion au rejet
passionnés dans le rapport de 30 ans en
disant que quand on travaillait sur le
aussi sur le schéma directeur
informatique on avait en même temps des
gens à plein temps pour travailler
dessus
je mets en tout cas il est évident que
faire appel à des prestations de conseil
sans avoir en face des gens qui peuvent
les
dirigez commande est métabolisé ce qu'il
donne
mettre en oeuvre est vraiment de
l'argent jeté par les fenêtres dans ce
cas là donc effectivement
les le pilotage ne se délègue pas
absolument le pilotage ne se délègue pas
et le le cabinet de conseil ne peut pas
être un substitut à la manière de
penser et à ses ça me paraît évident et
un dernier point parce que je voulais
pas frustré mais mes collègues de leurs
questions sur le pro bono vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure pas de pro bono
chez vous ça répond à un nombre de nos
questions mais quand même des
interventions bénévoles c'est l'objectif
que vous avez retenu pendant la crise
sanitaire feu dont d'ailleurs on peut
évidemment se louer mais je voulais
savoir quel était le statut de ces
personnes qui intervenait ce qu'il ya
une notion contractuels quand même avec
elle alors d'abord sur le pro bono j'ai
vu que c'était une de vos questions
je ferai la part de deux choses car
je trouve que le pro bono des cabinets
de conseil pour des associations des
organismes à but non lucratif etc est
extraordinairement utile 1 mais moi j'en
ai bénéficié dans des associations que
je présidais d'avoir des des
cabinets qui je fonce au titre du
mécénat
viennent aider des organismes qui eux
n'ont pas les moyens d'avoir une
direction de la stratégie et de la
transformation
et ça
et parieurs qui le font sans se dire que
dans la suite ça sera de leur passé un
contrat à deux millions d'euros ils
savent très bien qu'on peut pas le faire
un jour donné qu'on pourra pas le faire
l'année d'après donc ça ce pro bono là
me paraît la fois légitime utile
productif et d'ailleurs
pour je vais presque dire vertueux
en revanche
dans des organismes comme les nôtres ou
non pas sur l'or parce qu'on a des
difficultés à boucler les fins de mois
si je puis dire mais qu'avant des
budgets de 8 milliards etc je trouve que
le pro bono et qu'on est habitué à faire
des commandes publiques que le pro bono
n'a pas de sens ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre kader si des clients comme nous
pro bono je pense que c'est posera un
problème cabinet de conseil donc je vois
pas quel est leur intérêt de faire et si
nous
on va pas se mettre à dire que
[Musique]
l'électricité va être provocant va pas
aller faire le tour de nos fournisseurs
pour dire fait du probo il ya des
marchés de la concurrence et on essaye
d'avoir les prix les plus bas possibles
et donc il ya un risque que
un engagement pro bono puisse être une
manière de se rendre indispensable
après une prestation je pense que ça
je continue à dire que il se trouve que
nous n'y avons pas eu recours pendant la
crise
les circonstances étaient tellement
exceptionnel que
ça aurait pu arriver
ça n'a pas été un choix de refus
catégorique
ensuite les
les bénévoles
qui ont
officié à l'assistance publique ça s'est
fait dans un cadre
conventionnel de
reconnaissance alors j'avoue ne pas
savoir comment il sait comment il s'est
formalisé
préciserait je vous le précise ray bien
sur les toits la cl c'est
merci beaucoup je vais maintenant
proposer un nicole duranton de poser sa
question c'est qu'est merci monsieur le
président donc
chez le président
je vous remercie également pour les
propos clairs et précis que vous nous
avez apporté donc vous avez déjà répondu
à quelques questions que je me posais
néanmoins j'en ai donc d'autres vous
posez donc le boston consulting group
vous à aider à affiner les prévisions
donc des besoins de renforts sur la base
d'un modèle
épidémiologique donc quelles étaient les
spécificités de cette mission besoin de
renfort vis-à-vis des autres missions de
santé confiée à des cabinets de conseil
et de quelle façon le boston consulting
group at il défini les critères de son
modèle
épidémiologique et j'ai une dernière
question donc les cabinets c'est y
répondre at il seulement à des commandes
publiques précise de la part des
organismes de santé ou exerce-t-il
également rôles stratégiques d'appui à
la décision
je vous remercie
je crois vraiment à ma connaissance que
nous nous n'avons pas eu recours mon
collaborateur me confirme nous avons pas
eu recours au bcg à l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de paris a peut-être
d'autres organismes qui ont fait appel
il nous est indiqué que bcg sera
intervenu sur un modèle de prévision des
appels celle qu on avait une question je
complète je m'autorise à compléter sur
le sur les précautions qui ont peut être
pris de cet hôtel
alors
à ma connaissance les prévisions sur les
appels samu ont été travaillées entre
l'assistance publique un autre organisme
public et l'inria
que vous connaissez qu'est le grand
établissement public alors est-ce qu'il
ya eu du bcg de don
de notre côté g je reste transparent
avec monsieur directeur général c'est la
communication du boston consulting group
que nous avons là qui ciblent ap hp sur
cette mission là mais peut-être est-ce
que ça n'est pas vous qui l'avez comment
le samu c'est chez moi donc j'en suis
responsable donc à un jeu je vais
vérifier s'ils
s'y sont intervenus mais en tout cas
mais aujourd'hui vous nous communiquez
déjà pas il y avait une chose très
substantielles car en revanche il ya un
grand travail entre avec
le l'inria qui était donc ce grand
organisme public et c'est ça ce qui a
permis ces dunes riaa qui là qu'il a
développé de développer un
objectif dans un algorithme ont un
modèle que nous utilisons encore
aujourd'hui qui est un modèle prédictif
qui nous permet de dire qu'on les
appelle au samu augmente qu'est ce qui
risque de se passer dix jours après m 15
jours après alors que je sais pas si le
bcg les isles un peu aidés
mais parce qu'il est clair pour tout le
monde mais c'était une prestation pro
bono indiqué par le bcg d'accord mais je
vais vérifier cela vous voyez ça n'est
pas non non vous nous donnerez les
éléments de vence par écrit si vous
voulez bien et en précisant quelles sont
les précautions qui ont été prises
autour de faire de cette consultation
il y avait d'autres questions de
[Musique]
excusez moi monsieur le président oui
donc mon autre question c'était les
cabinets de conseil répond t-il
seulement à décommander commande
publique précise de la part des
organismes de santé ou exerce-t-il un
rôle stratégique d'appui à la décision
donc à l'assistance publique c'est que
des rôles précis
je ne connais pas la politique d autres
d autres organismes
et bien nathalie goulet pardon en ligne
et ensuite tu rends laurent burgoa
nathalie
cette audition a quelque chose
d'extrêmement éthiques
apparemment
de ce qu'il en ressort plutôt que
d'attendre le poisson vous avez décidé
d'apprendre à pêcher ce qui me semble
quand même une très bonne dynamique
alors moi j'ai deux remarques pas j'ai
deux questions la première est ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut réglementer ou
interdire le démarchage
c'est ce qu'on a fait par exemple avec
les laboratoires et serra auprès des
médecins lorsque on a
voté un certain nombre de textes sur
la déontologie ou après les scandales le
sanitaire donc est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut réglementer voire interdire
le démarchage en tous les cas vous étiez
personnel d'adp exclu
la deuxième chose
cet homme dans vos explications en
réalité il ya deux types d'actions il ya
vraiment le recours au cabinet conseil
et puis il ya la sous traitance donc je
sais pas comment vous avez établi la
réponse au
questionnaire qui vous a été transmis
mais je pense qu'il ya une très grande
différence dans votre démarche entre une
sous traitance on peut parfaitement
comprendre par exemple pour les
cotations d'actes et et elle conseille
qui rentre pas à mon sens dans la même
catégorie donc je pense qu'il ya une
différence à faire de ce point de vue
également au niveau des montants mais ma
question est plutôt sur sur le
démarchage que vous avez décidé
d'interdire je vous remercie
sur le démarchage
je pense que
je pense que c'est compliqué d'interdire
et que
l'interdiction peut susciter des moyens
détournés de se retrouvent quoi on va
pas interdire aux gens de se rencontrer
qu'en
et donc le jeu je suis
en train de réfléchir mais
je pense que ça aboutirait à des choses
finalement moins contrôlable je trouve
que le fait d'avoir à rendre des comptes
vous allez recevoir didier migaud dans
un instant qui était président de la
cour des comptes quand nous avons été
contrôlés
de
pouvoir rendre des comptes sur combien
on dépense dans quelles conditions d'
analyse des marchés comment ils ont été
conclus voire de donner des directives
me paraît
me paraît plus opérants que et puis
d'avoir effectivement de rappeler un
certain de de règles sur les liens
d'intérêts les conflits d'intérêts etc
je pense aussi plus utile
utile de faire en sorte que
notamment quand il ya des
congrès
en cuisine nous même si sa part une
dépense qui parfois critiquables payer
les déplacements de nos personnels
plutôt qu'ils acceptent une invitation
d'un daim de quelqu'un qui peut être
ensuite
notre notre fournisseur donc plutôt
d'avoir un cadrage des règles et des
relations plutôt qu'une interdiction du
du démarchage et je pense par ailleurs
qu'il va
ensuite la différence entre démarchage
et échanges
il est souvent très intéressant d'avoir
une discussion avec avec des des
consultants qui ont vu des hôpitaux hors
de france cet état je trouve que ces
échanges sont peuvent être très utiles
aux décideurs et donc je fais juste sur
le démarchage des visiteurs médicaux
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas organisé par la
loi nous nous l'avons prévu dans notre
règlement intérieur mais la loi
n'interdit pas le démarchage par les
visiteurs médicaux dans les hôpitaux
merci laurent burwell mon développement
oui merci monsieur le monsieur le
président madame le reporter merci
monsieur le directeur général pour la
franchise de vos propos notamment comme
a pu le dire notre président assure on
va dire vos relations avec les cabinets
conseil privé j'aurai deux petites
questions pour compléter peut-être
certaines entreprises
par rapport à ces cabinets conseil privé
dont on s'étonne que vous avez souhaité
justement éviter d'être en contact avec
eux est ce que vous auriez reçu des
recommandations
de personnes extérieures et notamment
d'un sens du teil pour recevoir certains
cabinets conseils et ma deuxième
question c'est toujours par rapport à
ces cabinets conseils aussi que des fois
des salariés c'est camille conseil par
une des grès les hôpitaux de paris ou
des herses à des salariés des hôpitaux
de paris pour aller vers ces cabinets
conseils si tel était le cas est ce que
vous auriez mis en place
une charte d anthologie par rapport à
ses salariés qui irait du public vers le
privé ou du privé vers le public
alors sur le premier point
très précisément le samedi
14 mars
et effectivement moi j'ai eu
un appel
à l'époque du cabinet du premier
ministre pour me dire il ya plusieurs
grands cabinets de conseil qui se sont
manifestés pour aider voilà intel intel
si tu veux tu peux les appeler ils sont
dispo pour faire du pro bono un pas pour
toi donc je te le dis sincèrement je dis
les choses
à part cela je n'ai je crois jamais reçu
de d'injonction de mai tutelle de faire
appel
à un
consultant
orange a vu quelques consultant
expliqué qu'
il était très bien en cours avec les
ministres mais ministre président de la
république et serra quand je me souviens
d'un
et qu il m'arriverait des tas d'ennuis
si je ne faisais plus appel à lui voilà
ça j'ai vu ça c'est des petits cabinets
qui font ça
j'ai parcours et et vous avez souligné
que j'étais toujours là mais bat donc
mais je n'ai jamais eu de
d'injonctions à
faire appel deuxièmement oui ces
passages existe
de notre côté c'était dans le
questionnaire les questionnaires je n'ai
pas connaissance entre 2018 2021 mais
soit en 2016 soit de 17 6 1 un des
directeurs de l'assistance publique est
parti dans un grand cabinet de conseil
qui doit de vice-président de ce ce
grand cabinet de conseil
et il l'a fait après
passage devant la la
la la commission qui doit se dit pour
tout flash quoi qui doit se prononcer là
dessus
et avec
l'impossibilité de nous avoir comme
comme client en tout cas
800 mails an dans les trois ans qui
suivent
donc le cas de figure c'est ses produits
et donc nous avons ces règles moi je lui
il n'y a pas de
on a un collège de déontologie qui peut
être saisie des cas qui poserait des
problèmes non résolus par la loi ou par
les commissions qui existe
qui est
saisi par des
parlers par les personnes concernées
12h20 une vingtaine de saisine par an
moi je pense qu'à du côté de des équipes
auxquelles je faisais allusion tout à
l'heure sion canton internalise il est
assez logique qu'on aille
recruter des gens qui étaient dans des
cabinets de conseils auparavant pas si
effectivement ils connaissent d'autres
acteurs ils ont d'autres méthodes etc et
il peut être assez logique
je pense que une des conditions pour que
ça fonctionne le le conseil interne
c'est que les gens n'y restent pas 30
ans
donc
nous les les personnes qui viennent dans
notre direction de la stratégie ils ont
trois débouchés possibles ils ont un
premier débouché qui est assez utilisé
qui est de passer de je suis au siège de
la paix je travaille sur l'ensemble des
blocs opératoires et on a créé des
fonctions de qu'on appelle d'autres
directeur des opérations et de chez pas
quoi mais qui
vont du coup plus près du terrain faire
des choses avec une bonne connaissance
ça c'est un premier débouché possible
qu'ils aient un deuxième débouché qui
est d'aller dans l'eau d'autres secteurs
public et il ya un troisième débouché
qui est d'aller dans des entreprises
dans des entreprises de conseil je
préfère que c'est ce débouchés existent
y compris le dernier plutôt que d'avoir
des gens qui
qui à la fin
serait un peu émoussé dans car je pense
que c'est des équipes qui doivent qui
doivent tourner pour garder leur leur
efficacité et ensuite il me semble que
les règles telles qu'elles sont fixés
depuis quelques années pour le passage
en comité de déontologie sont ne semble
satisfaisante
je peux prolonger juste un tout petit
peu cette question parce que vous avez
évoqué les réserves qui sont indiqués
par la commission par la haute autorité
sur le pantouflage est ce que ces
réserves vous avez moyen de vérifier en
interne qu'elles sont bien impliqués
dans notre institution
oh oui
oui on a moyen de le vérifier parce que
d'abord cd cd petit nombre de gens
identifiés et de règles qui sont connus
donc je pense que on a moyen de les
vérifier et épais rieur ces règles sont
ces règles sont partagés ces règles sont
partagés un point là dessus pour dire
que cas ces questions d'éthique font
partie des choses qu'on qu'on évoque
dans les comités de direction dans le
cadre acquis qui sont pas quoi qu'ils
ont bien des choses taboues du tout au
contraire c'est la meilleure manière de
le de les faire connaître et donc je
pense qu'il ya un état d'esprit dans
lequel on
sait questions déontologiques sont sont
partagés ensuite j'ai une immense c'est
une immense maison dans lesquelles il
peut
il se passe parfois des choses que je
découvre a posteriori vous avez
peut-être vu ce week end que ça mais
encore arrivé
c'est pour ça que c'est un processus
quelque chose d'installer justement pour
ça pour avoir cette
surveillance de l'application de ces
clauses il ya
le partage de ces consignes avec
l'ensemble des directeurs et notamment
des directions sensibles que sont la
direction des systèmes d'information et
la direction de la stratégie qui sont
les deux directions qui sont les plus
les plus sensibles et effectivement
ce réflexe existe quoi va donc c'est
merci valérie boyer parole maintenant
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général
je vous ai écouté attentivement j'ai
deux petites questions concernant les
relations de l'ap hp avec les ars
puisque je crois savoir que les ars ont
utilisé des cabinets conseils donc je
voulais savoir quelles étaient les
relations vous pouviez entretenir entre
les ars et les cabinets conseils qui
travaille pour le compte des ars parce
que si vous même vous n'avez pas utilisé
directement de cabinet conseil en fait
ce cabinet conseil pouvait être
indirectement
comment dire avoir une voix pour
l'ap-hp en tout cas à venir en support
si oui quoi et comment et ensuite
je voulais savoir si sur les prestations
qu'ils avaient et 8 et qui avait été
utilisé avec lesquels vous avez pu être
mis en relation c'était des prestations
pro bono ou des prestations
payantes suivant un marché
voilà parce que
c'est ma première question à mon autre
question et sur les liens entre les les
cabinets conseils et la dss avec qui
vous êtes forcément en relations
étroites
c'est la même question comment ces
choses-là pouvait se passer parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un établissement
comme le vôtre
n'utilisent pas ces cabinets conseils
toutes les administrations avec lesquels
vous travaillez les en utiliser donc on
est dans le même écosystème si je puis
dire
où cette intrication
avec les cabinets conseil est importante
et enfin une dernière petite question
sous jacente
à votre avis
dans cette relation
ap hp ars ile-de-france et
et administrations d'état pour
simplifier
quel est à votre avis la part de l'aide
à la prise de décision et parce que
c'est vrai qu'il peut paraître
surprenant que dans le monde de la santé
qui est quand même très administrée avec
des personnes de grande qualité qui ont
des parcours extrêmement variés qu'ils
connaissent en profondeur toutes les
arcanes de l'hôpital ou de la médecine
de ville on utilise et on a utilisé
l'assurance maladie bien évidemment
étant incluses dans dans ma question on
utilise on a utilisé
à des auteurs qui sont quand même très
élevé des cabinets conseils donc
vraiment pour avoir connu dans une autre
vie la qualité des personnes qui
travaillent dans ces administrations
c'est vrai qu'on peut être surpris de
d'imaginer de constater que des cabinets
conseils connaissent mieux
que que ces directeurs de la sécurité
sociale ou de l'assurance maladie ou ou
des ars le monde de la santé
voilà ma question merci beaucoup
madame la sénatrice boyer pour c'est
pour pour ces questions est
effectivement
la question que vous posez sur la rn je
vais répondre de deux manières
il se trouve qu'il ya quatre ans avec la
rs ile de france
la rs l'ile-de-france jusqu'à il ya
quatre ans
financé nous permettait d'avoir un droit
de tirage sur des cabinets de conseils
discuter tout à fait tu peux être utile
alors donc du coup on les payait pas
et on tirait sur des prestations avec
avec des cabines et on s'est dit que
c'était pas sain et donc on a transformé
les mêmes sommes pour plus tôt
depuis 2018 donc nous avons une
convention avec la rs qui a couvert 2018
2021 on a une deuxième 2021 2023 en
disant quand à utiliser ces sommes
soient justement pour recruter ses
compétences avec des cdd ce qu'on a fait
par exemple sur toute la dimension
développement durable est un enjeu
majeur pour les établissements soit avec
plutôt des écoles par exemple les écoles
de design sur
la transformation des deux de
l'organisation hospitalière donc 2 où il
ya des des étudiants et des profs et
donc de pouvoir les financer pour
travailler avec nous et donc on a fait
une mutation excusez moi je vous
interromps souvent cédé des financements
en provenance de la grèce ouais c'est
tout à fait absolument vous n'avez pas
de marché enfin vous n'utilisez pas le
marché de la déité p il nous est arrivé
d'utiliser le marché de la delhi tpg
fait référence sans citer la déité paix
sur l'aspect logistique et logement
c'était des marchés d'élite et paix
sur les sommes que j'ai que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure et donc la rs avait cela
et donc à une une convention qui
s'appelle d'atos je sais pas ce que ça
veut dire mais
qui au début j'étais
je peux voir pour du consultant et qu'on
a fait
en quarts conjointement avec la rs
évoluer vers vers du travail vers
l'internalisation et les écoles et c'est
souvent là je trouve que c'est
particulièrement
intéressant la deuxième chose je crois
moi je lis tous les jours on ya 2 les
tableaux de bord qui sont faits là dans
le cadre du coc jean
effectivement
celui de l' agence régionale de santé a
été développé avec un cabinet de conseil
je crois entre les deux vagues ou à la
fin de la première vague
nous nous avons un tableau de bord de
suivi qui a été fait par
complètement en interne celui on trouve
tous les jours le nombre de
contaminations le nombre de patients
real nombre de patients hospitalisés en
quoi toute une série de 50 pages
d'indicateurs qui nous sert de boussole
les deux sont bien faits
ensuite nous nous avons effectivement je
pense plus de n'avait plus des
expertises médicales et techniques et et
pour pour pour pau pour faire pour faire
cela
ensuite alors on a en fait très peu de
relations avec la direction de la
sécurité sociale directement nous
on en a vraiment avec la rs on en a un
peu avec la cnam la des jouets semer la
dss c'est au moment où ils vérifient
notre budget mais
peu dans la réponse à la question que
vous posez en disant comment ça se fait
que des consultants extérieurs peuvent
sur un sujet finalement paraître plus
compétents que quelqu'un qui est depuis
15 ans alors
revient qu'à moi je crois vraiment que
le petit fils que vous j'ai l'impression
que vous tirez sur se doter de deux
capacités de conseil interne est majeur
quoi parce que c'est des profils qui
seront pas les mêmes profils que ceux
qui gèrent depuis
quelques années le même dispositif qui
ne se remettront pas en cause compass
qui s' ils le gèrent beaucoup ont pas
les moyens de voir ce qui se passe
ailleurs qui sont communs donc d'avoir
des gens qui peuvent avoir un regard
distancié extérieur nourrit d'autres
d'autres expériences
et qu'il y passe quelques années
je pense que c'est c'est
des choses qui sont très utiles donc
que de pouvoir avoir
peut-être dans l'est dans les directions
où les grands établissements bully quoi
comme on nous on essaye de le comme on
essaie de le faire d'avoir une petite
équipe avec un fort turnover une forte
compétence et qui sont déjà en fête qui
sont des j'allais dire quasiment des
jumeaux des consultants ils ont souvent
fait les mêmes écoles
c'est une manière de pouvoir donc pour
répondre je pense pas que ça soit et je
suis sûr que non ce n'est pas une
question
d'incompétence
des responsables de telle ou telle
administration service au ministère que
d'avoir besoin d'avoir rappelle un
regard extérieur je rajoute et je le
vois que
les dimensions systèmes d'information
sont d'une telle technicité d'une telle
qu'on plie complexité que
effectivement vous avez des spécialistes
qui
en nombre relativement limité qui
peuvent apporter une expertise hyper
pointu et c est qu il est parfois
difficile d'internaliser
elle leur apporte
oui sur cette petite digression monsieur
le directeur général peut être que sur
ces sujets si on se préoccuper davantage
de la rémunération des personnels de la
fonction publique hospitalière comme de
l'ensemble de la fonction publique peut
être qu'on aurait moins de problèmes
comme ceux que vous avez évoquées
j'ai une question ou en s'est quand même
passé un événement à l'ami 2021 vous
avez subi une attaque une super attaque
il ya un service de sécuriser partage de
fichiers et la cnil a été informé de
cette chute de données concernant quand
même 1,4 million de personnes testées
contre la copie de 19 alors même qu
accenture a été missionné pour
l'élaboration de la vision et de la
pérennisation du système d'information
vaccination sur le fondement des données
cidep est ce que vous pourriez nous dire
quelles précautions vous mettez en
oeuvre pour vis-à-vis de ses
prestataires c'est quand même un sujet
alors
oui donc cidep
nous sommes maîtres d'oeuvre pour le
ministre de la santé qui est maître
d'ouvragé du système que vous connaissez
que vous avez tous
utilisés pas du tout pour le vaccin qui
est juste le dépistage et
le
d'abord si vous permettez
de rendre hommage aux équipes qui ont
fait ce à quoi on s'est retrouvé
rapidement à devoir
avoir un défi dans un hôpital
d'accepter la demande qui a été faite
par le ministre de la santé de montrer
le système national
jeudi devant la représentation nationale
mais avoir réussi à brancher toutes les
pharmacies tous les laboratoires
d'analysés labat vétérinaires etc etc
tous tous tous pour que effectivement
tous les jours remonte les 500000
résultats positifs et des résultats
négatifs heureusement encore plus
nombreux a été un exploit extraordinaire
ils l'ont fait avec de la sous traitance
donc il ya eu quand cette ce système qui
a été monté dans un temps record et qui
a été a été conduit à voir ses
spécifications changé à peu près tous
les deux mois d'abord il y avait que les
tests pcr puis ensuite sur les
antigénique puis ensuite il ya les
autotests puis ensuite il ya eu toute
une catégorie de laboratoire quand c'est
un
chantier absolument dantesque qui a de
temps en temps des petits bugs quand
tout d'un coup il ya deux millions de
personnes qui se testent le même jour et
qu'on avait prévu de monter un mur et
demi mais est ce qui pour moi est une
réussite alors effectivement si vous
l'analysez c'est une réussite qui s'est
fait en partenariat public-privé part
c'était de la prestation du conseil le
privé c'est de la prestation c'est de la
prestation est ce qu'il ya un peu de
conseils ou pas mais pas c'est celle de
la prestation de serment de la
prestation majoritairement de la
prestation sans un sens sans aucun doute
et si vous si vous auditionner les
maîtres d'oeuvre de cela vous verrez que
ils savent eux mêmes expliqué de a
jusqu'à z leur dit qu on comprenait
pourquoi on veut justement cette
précision oui bien sûr bien sûr en se
liant très important et et pour être
transparents je vais vous dire le
montant des prestations je crois que
c'est 30 millions d'euros c'est de cet
ordre de grandeur donc on est bien au
dessus
mais le le le cadrage
l'architecturé a été faite alors
justement en recrutant des expertises
externes de polytechniciens et autres
qui sont venus qu'on a embauchés sur des
cdd pour le faire à l'intérieur
voilà pour l'audition de martin hirsch
le directeur général de la pêche